i'm also very thankful for the for the
judicial system
jamie spears is speaking out through his
lawyers after the framing britney spears
documentary sparked
new interest in the free brittany
movement what do we want
free britney when do we want it now
a statement from jamie's legal team to
e.t reads in part
my client jamie spears has diligently
and professionally
carried out his duties as one of
brittany's conservators
and his love for his daughter and
dedication to protecting
her is clearly apparent to the court
i was involved as an attorney of record
for the first few months of the
conservatorship proceedings
our client was jamie spears brittany's
father
i can't talk about anything specifically
that i did but i guess i could talk
about it in a
more like hypothetical situation that's
jamie's lawyer vivian lee thorin
participating in the dock while she was
on a break from jamie's legal team
she has since rejoined have you ever
known anyone who has terminated a
conservative yet
of the cases that i've been involved in
i have not seen
a conservative who has successfully
terminated a conservatorship
framing britney spears raised concerns
over the restrictions on brittany's life
but in the statement jamie's team says
quote from the beginning the court has
closely monitored brittany's situation
including annual accountings and
in-depth reviews and recommendations
from a highly experienced
and dedicated court investigator jamie
was granted conservatorship over
brittany in 2008
after she faced a series of high-profile
struggles
if i wasn't under the restraints that
i'm under right now you know with
all the lawyers and doctors and people
analyzing me every day and
all that kind of stuff like if that
wasn't there i'd feel
so liberated and feel like myself
that's brittany that same year in an mtv
documentary
one of the only times she's talked about
the legal arrangement
i don't understand how he can be such an
ass and be so nice
it's true love brittany in 2020 through
her lawyer
brittany nominated bessemer trust to
take over conservatorship duties for her
finances
and the judge granted them
co-conservatorship status alongside
jaime in the statement jamie's lawyers
say he quote
looks forward to working with bessemer
to continue an investment strategy in
the best interests of his daughter
i am so proud of
each lawyer that represented our family
in this
e-t spoke with framing britney spears
director samantha stark about the
logistics of brittany's legal situation
what do you think is the future of her
conservatorship
having been to the hearings and and done
all the research that you've done where
do you see it going
yeah i mean i think a lot of people see
a lot of symbolism and this idea that
her father is controlling her like
symbolic of the patriarchy but actually
literally um
but uh you know
these court uh hearings keep it's it's
lasted a long time and something that we
bring up in the film
you know is by looking at britney's
story there's a lot of questions we have
about the conservatorship system and if
there's like areas where it could
possibly
there could be conflicts of interest so
for example brittany is paying for
her own lawyers and she's also paying
for her father's lawyers
and she pays for the her conservators as
well
and so um some people could see
opportunity for there to be a conflict
of interest because as long as the
conservatorship keeps going all those
people keep getting paid
um and also paying for lawyers to argue
against each other is so
unique so
my prediction is it's going to last a
long time
you